A lot's happened in the last ten years.
It's a miracle I'm even sitting here now.
I got a second chance
and I'm going to take advantage of that.
But I need you with me, Pete.
We’re going to heal the world.
Guys, this is my best friend, Harry.
Hey. Good to meet you.
New job, huh?
Still going to have time for tutoring?
We'll figure it out.
I didn't know there were bears in these woods.
Hey, M.J.
I have another name for you.
Kraven.
And he's here on some kind of hunt.
You know if you need me, I'm just a call away.
Li.
You don't know what you took from me.
All Miles talks about his how to be a better Spider-Man
How to help you.
The hell is going on with Pete?
He's not himself.
Go help him
This was our dream.
I'm not going to lose you.
We're going to heal the world.